Họng định vị thêm phòng, Vên BC đầu tư nhà máy Vóx sinh hiện đại hơn hai nhiên năm 2018,
sản xuất các phóx sinh hiện mối của pháp giảm chí phi têm trụ trời lần.
Tại hội nghĩ cấp cao Vên Nam pháp mềm mùi xin tháng bệnh,
với chủ đề tăng cường hợp tác triển khai công vệ trở lực,
sản phẩm công vệ trở lực về phóch sinh Vóx sinh hiện mối tại Vên Nam.
Công tin Vóx sinh Vên Nam, Vên BC và tập đàn xa Lu phi pháp, công bộ bức tiến trong vực tác,
hướng tươi sản xuất phóx sinh hiện mối tại nhà máy Vóx sinh vóx sinh vóx sinh phòng vên BC từ Nam hai nghi khu chăm khá mi tâm.
Tại hội nghĩ Vên BC và sản xuất phi có mối những mức tiến mối trong tin trình hụt tác,
sản xuất phóx sinh công nghệ cao của sản xuất hóp vên tại nhà máy Vóx sinh vóx sinh vóx sinh phòng vên BC.
Tại lộ trình, sản xuất vên BC sẽ hụt tác, sản xuất một số phóx sinh tiếp êu có nhiều cầu cao cho chế em và người lớn của sản xuất phi.
Rồi kênh lộ vóx sinh quan trọng phị hệ mối đầu tiên của Sanofi sẽ được sản xuất tại Vinh Nam từ Nam hai nghi khu chăm khá mi tâm.
Vên BC cũng cập nhật tình độ sư dựng nhà máy Vóx sinh và sinh phòng vên BC.
Dàng một các vóx sinh tị hệ mối được ư tiến sản xuất nhằm đáp êu cầu tiến trung cho lựng cao cho chế em và người lớn tại Vinh Nam.
Nhà máy Vóx sinh và sinh phòng vên BC sẽ kiến đi vào hạt động vào cuối năm hai nghi khu chăm hai mi bây.
Sản xuất phóx sinh từ Nam hai nghi khu chăm hai mi tâm và thương hại hoa các vóx sinh tị hệ mối từ hai nghi khu chăm hai mi chính.
Dự ăn sản đáp êu vên sinh mối giống dân bục phóx sinh trong trường trình tin trung cuối ra,
có phần ra tăng cơ hội tức cận các vóx sinh tị hệ mối trong người dân với chi ví đầu tư tự ưu.
Vên BC cũng chia sẻ một tiêu phóx sinh thành trung tâm mi in kêu.
Tức miển công nghệ.
Sản xuất và kiến điện phóx sinh.
Xin phòng công nghệ cao hàng đầu viên 5 và khu vực.
Trong đó, nhà máy công nghệ cao là niên tảng để viên BC chỉ khai các trường trình hợp tác công nghệ với các đời tác quốc tế.
Viên như kiếu hiện đại là điểm đến tu hút các nghi ngủ khu học cho các rại vóx sinh tị hệ mối.
Trong nhiều năm qua, viên BC đã đổ từ phóx sinh hệ sinh thái vóx sinh tần dự với gần 8 trong trung tâm tin trung trình tăng cuối.
Hệ thống bảo quan vóx sinh và trình hai tin trung an toàn.
Chỉ ví hợp lý trình tăng cuối.
Zú hàng trục triệu trẻ em và người lớn sẽ giang tiếp cận BC để hệ mối bảo vệ xu khuyện.